m
c'est au moca que le conseil
départemental et la région réunion ont
co organisé la fête des lanternes à
l'occasion du nouvel an chinois
l'occasion de mettre à l'honneur la
communauté chinoise de la réunion mais
également de réunir les réunionnais
toutes confessions confondues
à la réunion on sommes au fond sur une
paire de réunion et de réunions de
culture de réunions de culte et j'ai
presque envie de dire aussi de métissage
de population la réunion vit avec cet
être à culturalité et il ya en chacun de
nous un peu de l'européen un peu de la
chine de l'asie un peu de l'ain un peu
de l'afrique et c'est toute la richesse
de la population réunionnaise et même de
l'unité qui lie à une unité dans la
diversité et au delà de cette fête nous
avons plaisir à accueillir les
réunionnais nous voulons donner du sens
à cette unité à notre vivre ensemble
cette nouvelle année remercier la chèvre
de bois et accueille le singe de feu en
nouveaux maîtres symbole de l'imprévu
l'homme et du singe réserve des moments
de grâce et de très belles surprises
c'étaient les messages sage parce que
c'est un symbole qui porte bonheur
alors ça veut dire que y'a
l'intelligence la créativité
ah bien sûr la caf la caprice aussi
alors c'est une année encore dit que
tout peut arriver mais alors avec toutes
les forces on a les bras à tous régions
et départements se sont associés pour
honorer cette tradition une première
cette année qui laisse présager de beaux
projets communs pour les deux
collectivités
nous avons toujours dit que nous avions
à travailler ensemble dans l'intérêt
général dans l'intérêt de la réunion et
je suis très heureux que cette
manifestation sera marquée quelque part
déjà donc cette volonté d'un travail de
coordination entre le conseil
départemental et la région et nous
aurons bien sûr tout au long de l'année
dans le cadre de la conférence
territoriale des politiques publiques
que nous avons créé hier en assemblée
plénière nous aurons l'opportunité sur
d'autres sujets des sujets comme les
transports comme le traitement des
déchets
peut faire ensemble que nous puissions
coordonnées encore une fois l'action des
collectivités locales
le public a pu profiter de nombreux
spectacles mis en place par des
associations les traditionnelles danses
du dragon et bellion comme chaque année
enchanté les visiteurs un village a
également été mise en place afin que le
public puisse découvrir la culture
chinoise
alors ce soir comme tous les ans donc je
démontre disons le l'art ancestral
chinois qui l'expliques-tu sur fruits et
légumes qui servait à l'époque donc
sublimer les tables des mandarins à la
cour voilà et c'est pour montrer
également qu'avec juste un goûter gül on
peut arriver à quelque chose de
magnifique
dans le cadre de la fête des lanternes à
bibliothèque pourquoi la réalisation
d'une petite lanterne avec du beau
papier chinois qui est suspendu un petit
bonbon
voilà chacun peut repartir à ty long
terme une soirée festive et conviviale
dans le cadre exceptionnel du moca
rendez-vous en 2017 pour l'année du coq
de feu